we've all been there
no matter the franchise when you're
waiting for news about your favorite
game
days can feel like months months can
feel like years
and years well years can feel like a
lifetime
experts agree that at least 9 out of 10
video game players will experience
suffering from a video game drought at
least once in their lifetime
that's why today i am pleased to present
to you 10 ways that you can survive
the drought number one play minecraft
you can always
play minecraft number two distract
yourself
go to the gym buy a pet or two
or three remind yourself of your past
heartbreaks
[Music]
number three buy a zelda game you
haven't played and play it
you know you haven't played them all
number four
buy lots and lots of expensive things to
make yourself feel better
number five sleep
[Music]
number six avoid unnecessary reminders
of the games you just can't get over
and stop liking their photos on social
media
it's okay to see other games number
seven
play minecraft it's still relevant
number eight
invest in experimental memory wiping
techniques and re-experience your
favorite games all over again
invest in experimental memory wiping
techniques and re-experience your fate
invest in experimental memory wiping
techniques and re-experience
number nine play minecraft it's always
relevant number ten re-evaluate your
life's decisions that led to your
current state of video game addiction
and admit to yourself that there is no
real reason to continually waste time
playing these pointless games
determine in your heart to better
yourself emotionally and
physically by removing video games from
your daily routine permanently and reap
immense rewards in the form of less
stress
more money a girlfriend or boyfriend and
a healthier state of mind
go on free yourself
[Music]
number 11 share this video number 12
like and subscribe and comment number 13
replay
[Music]
ah there are too many thorns and these
are my good pants